-Guys, it can be hard
to say goodbye,
but sometimes you have to,
and there are a few things
I'd like to say goodbye to
right now.
It's time for "Go On, Git."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Go on, git, go on, git ♪
♪ Go on, go on, go on, git ♪
[ Western guitar twanging ]
-Whoa.
♪♪
-Go on, git,
election touch screens.
Thanks for being
the iPads we needed...
and the TV no one asked for.
You served this country well,
but now it's time to git back
to the CNN supply closet
until 2024.
May you live to be pinched
and poked another day.
'Til then, breaking news,
you better go on to the git.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Go on, git, mahogany.
Oh, you think you're --
'cause you're a
straight-grained,
reddish-brown timber
with a range
that extends from South America
to North America
that you get to have
a four-syllable,
hoity-toity name
like "mahogany"?!
Here's a new name for you.
Tree.
Don't like that one?
Here's another one.
Wood.
Wham bam! Go on, git!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Go on, git,
daylight savings time.
Sure, it's fun
to switch things up,
but you know what else is fun?
Daylight!
The only things
I need less light for
are movie theaters
and laser tag.
And both of those
are on COVID hold.
Or HOVID, as I call it.
Besides, I'm tired of adjusting
my oven clock at your whim.
So why don't you spring forward,
fall back, and go on, git!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Spit ]
[ Ding! ]
Go on, git...
anteaters, ya big weirdos.
You look -- You look like
someone stuck a Dirt Devil
onto a dog's face and said,
"Hope you like ants."
[ Laughter ]
Well, I reckon
God created you for a reason,
and that reason
was for me to say,
"Thank you for eatin'
all the ants."
I do dislike ants.
You can stay, anteaters,
you weird-looking,
cone-faced beavers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Go on, git, old Hotmail address.
You were the first
e-mail address I ever had,
but you've outlived your
usefulness by about 20 years.
The only e-mails you get now are
Bed Bath & Beyond coupons,
links to adult websites,
and notifications from Myspace.
Now, go on, git,
KoolDude555@hotmail.com,
and don't let the barn door
hit you in the backside.
Well, it's hard to see 'em go,
but I'm glad
that I got it all out of my
system. We'll be right back.